وبشان الانباء عن محاولات اسرائيليه
لتوطين سكان غزه في الخارج قال وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني بلينكن انه يجب
ان يتمكن المدنيون الفلسطينيون من العوده
لديارهم ويجب عدم الضغط عليهم لمغادره
القطاع وانتقد بلينكن تصريحات بعض
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين الداعيه الى ذلك
وقال انها غير مسؤوله ومثيره
للجدل
يجب ان يتمكن المدنيون الفلسطينيون من
العوده الى ديارهم حالما تسمح الظروف
بذلك لا يمكن الضغط عليهم لمغادره غزه نحن
نرفض تصريحات بعض الوزراء والمشرعين
الاسرائيليين الداعيه الى توطين
الفلسطينيين خارج غزه هذه التصريحات غير
مسؤوله ومثيره للجدل ولا تؤدي الا الى
زياده صعوبه تامين مستقبل لغزه تحت قياده
فلسطينيه لن تسيطر فيه حماس على القطاع
ولن تكون الجماعات الارهابيه قادره على
تهديد امن اسرائيل